[Music]
hey guys for years the defining miss
really heart of game occurrence has been
who will sit on the Iron Throne when the
series is over in a span of six seasons
King's Landing has had four ruler
citizen throne of power Robert Baratheon
Joffrey and Tommen Lannister Baratheon
and now Cersei Lannister most of them
seem to support Jon's claim to his
father Rhaegar Targaryen as the show
made plain in the season 7 finale Justin
is not only regards bastard son but true
and legitimate heir to the Iron Throne
the Targaryen screwed Westeros for
hundreds of years and Prince Rhaegar was
legally Wed to Lyanna Stark making the
best urchins know an actual Prince Aegon
Targaryen if you follow the hereditary
monarchy just know just as bran Stark
stated is the rightful heir to the Iron
Throne however that's not all he wants
to take on but frankly he did not want
to be king in the north but he accepted
it for the sake of his people so he
might accept the role of the king of
Westeros for the sake of his people as
well some use the believe Littlefinger
wood outwit them all and take the throne
for himself and now that he's dead some
are speculating that Varys has important
role yet to play others on the other
hand loved to argue that Dany is the Chu
heir to the Iron Throne and deserves to
rule over the Seven Kingdoms then he
made reclaiming the iron turn on our
mission at the end of season one her
entire journey since then has been about
one thing making that happen whether
she'll seal the deal though is another
story entirely
some of the best players in the game
crowns tyrion and varys believe that
with the right counsel she'd make a
great ruler let's see the mid learn to
the prophecy about the princes promise
doesn't necessarily stand for a
male-only as the proper translation
prophecy is the prince or princess that
was promised it looks as if the show is
setting her up for success but that
might not be good for Dany
fans have learned their lesson about
predictability more than once with a
series leading us to consider a
possibility of daily dying in a
childbirth just like her own matter date
or even dying during the great war
against the night king but what if every
character fans see fit ruling vestro
star to die before the end of game
thrones in that case fans believe that
the night King would win and end up on
the Iron Throne with the night king
destroying huge portion of the wall and
marching south with huge army the dragon
more and more offensive thing
in the end he might sit on the throne
even though the night king will be a
huge danger for rest rose and even
though the living side will suffer
tremendous losses it's been pretty much
confirmed by George Armand that he will
be defeated eventually but at what cost
one would ask I said before that the
tone of the ending that I'm going for
his bittersweet
it ends with victory but it's a
bittersweet victory George Armand stated
according to The Daily Telegraph in 2015
George said something along the line
killing the night king will not be the
end of Game of Thrones and instead the
final battle will be with Cersei that's
a strong hint we will buy no less than
George our mark for this means is even
if jon snow dies fighting the night king
and Danny dies in childbirth the living
side would indeed lose great leaders but
the war would not be lost just yet it's
more likely that Tyrion will take the
leadership of the living side with Jaime
commanding and leading the army song is
the army of the Dead from it saying they
will take care of Jon and then his child
while the war is still ravaging long
story short if John and Danny are to die
in let's say episode 5 of season 8 the
final episode would see the living side
under Tyrians leadership against the
night King while Cersei would still be
on the throne basically the night king
will be defeated
sir civil sit on the Iron Throne while
Jon could die fighting the night king
and Danny could potentially die in
childbirth pretty bittersweet there's
even the Game of Thrones book clue
hinting that mirror Dany no Jon Snow
will end up rolling Westeros unlike the
TV show which is able to maintain an
omniscient viewpoint across the
sprawling example cast George are learns
the Song of Ice and Fire novels are told
from a strict third-person perspective
with each chapter told from a specific
characters singular point of view that
means the books can never feature scenes
between non point-of-view characters
what does this have to do with our
question who will win the game in terms
well once you've read all five of
Martin's now mostly becomes apparent
that the author never writes from the
point of view of a monarch King Robert
was never a point of view character
none of the would be rulers involved in
War of the five kings for Panama
characters near king-beyond-the-wall
mance rayder no young King Tommen
forever point um characters rather up
story was told from the perspective of
his mother Catelyn
sentences through Davos menses through
John Thomas or Cersei etcetera Sun West
Georgia Martin suddenly decides to
change the fundamental way he is
approached his story for five novels
thousands of pages sin 22 years nobody
who has been a point of your character
will end up on the earth
and yes sir she does have a point of new
chapters in the books but she's not
sitting on the Iron Throne as she does
in the show a showrunner st. George
Armand highlighted multiple times the
row towards the end of this amazing
journey will be different meaning some
characters that are dead in the show
will and actually already are alive in
the books and some characters are rollin
in the show do not rule in the books
however they also stated at the end of
this road will be the same meaning that
the ending will be the same and whoever
wins the game materials in the show will
win in the books as well in the end it's
likely that a Song of Ice and Fire will
end the same way it began as a story of
cripples bastards and broken things
another story of kings and queens so if
none of the stories protagonists are
destined to rule Westeros additionally
makers are likely to die then who will
win the game terms the assume
requirement that it be an on point of
your character certainly seems to
support a theory that Ginji will be the
king claiming the throne as a sole
surviving offspring of late King Robert
Baratheon ginjury as a sole living heir
to Robert Enke house Baratheon
altogether ginjuries a container were to
mention he's young he's fearless and He
wills that Warhammer just like his
father used to ginji's motivated solely
by revenge against the Lannisters so
killed his father and not at all by
power that would take him beyond and he
expected his what kick-started the
entire saga when Jon Arryn was killed
shortly after he found out the truth
about ginjury it will be quite at waste
if the search for an heir to the Seven
Kingdoms would actually end with him on
the Iron Throne Jo Dempsey who plays the
dark-haired blacksmith with the magical
Kings but told Digital Spy that even
though he wasn't sure he would ever
return to the series at all we are
probably going to see a lot of him in
the eighth and final season since he's
been filming a fair bit for the last six
episodes being a part of the endgame
means he is also whole raft of new
secrets to keep and it's not unthinkable
to think he could be holding on the
ultimate secret Genji will end the show
sitting on the Iron Throne there are
questions if a bastard could ever ascend
to the throne but it's still possible
that ginjury is in fact illegitimate son
King Robert as many believe he might be
Cersei's black haired son Cersei claims
he died shortly after his birth and
Cersei on the other hand might be the
blond hair mother Ginty remembers there
are plenty more clues to hints that
support his theory of Genji being a
legitimate son of Queen Cersei King
Robert Baratheon
if you'd like to see that make sure to
check out my previous videos animes
ginjury has another important blood
relation in his favor he's the
descendent of attack
robert's grandmother was princess
realtor garyun the youngest daughter of
King Aegon v Targaryen maesters uses
blood ties to hosta garyun to justify
straw birds claim after Robert's
rebellion although it was conquest which
won him the throne ginjuries his son
Robert and his both Baratheon Targaryen
blood and maybe even lain stirs that's a
pretty good start a few other things
would have to fall in place so rather a
few other people would have to fall for
a ginjury to end up on the throne but
we'll come back to that again you're
sitting on the Iron Throne might sound
impossible to some the idea that a minor
character who literally vanished
forehead the show's run could end up
winning but there's a quote from season
2 episode 7 that's always felt like it
could be a harbinger of the show's
endgame the quote says those on the
margins often come to control the center
and those in center make room for them
willingly or otherwise the character was
talking about himself and his position
in Qarth but on the show where the
matter of jungles was varying in a
desert and the legitimate son of Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna stark was hiding in
plain sight it carries a lot of meaning
for the entire show but what if the
answer is not as obvious as a major
character no one was more on the margins
than the injury but of course both the
John and Danny are still alive and both
will have much better claims to they
aren't rounding injury injuries part
Targaryen which along with him being the
last of the Baratheon line would give
him a claim to the Iron Throne if Danny
John inserts say all died during the
battle against nat king at the end the
most possible theory in my opinion
regarding who will win the game turns
and sit on the Iron Throne is no one
then he said she wanted to break the
wheel more than once sentir and agreed
with the Great War eventually being born
amid Cersei overthrown with or without
Danny alive it's quite possible that
will she wanted to break will be
shattered entirely a new world order
might be exactly what Westeros needs to
rebuild itself in my opinion Justin will
die fighting the night king Danny will
Dinah childbirth and Tyrion will be
named Lord regent and protector of the
realm to rule in John and then instead
until their child comes of age Tyrion
will then break up the Kingdom and
allowed various parts of it to
self-govern once again fulfilling
Danny's ratio breaking the wheel and in
fact ending the game appearance once for
all describing Danny's final on-screen
moments Emilia Clarke told Vanity Fair
it [ __ ] knowing that is going to be a
lasting flavor in someone's mouth or
what Danny is this sounds interesting
had an historian it goodwill Clark
really feel this way or is it just the
total funding that makes her feel this
way even more intriguing Lee Clark added
that Danny will be doing all this field
in season 8 and adding you'll know what
I mean when you see it uh directors such
as an actress who plays brilliant old
dnews you're going to need therapy after
the final season's over
when reporter asks awesome dice Christy
replied I think just the show ending is
going to send all of the world in the
professional help for this behind that
history might come true John and Danny
died Tyrion survives and raises their
child unfulfilled any dreams perhaps
then again the recently released East
seems to be foreshadowing then Jon
survives the Game of Thrones with him
looking old on his statue hinting that
he might die it very old age it's kind
of possible that some of the Starks will
not survive the final season now is the
John who is heav Stark a Targaryen or is
otário or sensor brain is unclear
speaking to digital spy sophie turner
who plays sensible swift to dismiss the
idea that her new do peg survives the to
a stark slogan constitutes a spoiler
pointing out that would be terrible if i
got the ending the to do my body just
before the last season came out that
will be so stupid so if it's not
spoiling anything is it an official
confirmation that some of the Starks
star going to die maybe the teaser seems
to suggest that it might be sensor or
and are you with them looking young on
their statues however I would not say
just arriving is confirmed just because
he looks old nice at you for example the
tease of season six shows John's Tyrians
and in his face among go latter being in
the whole of faces did any of them die
in that season or did they join the
faceless men no they're for these days
is probably not spoiling fate of the
Starks
Amane but parole is not an actor who
plays shame lynnster hinted that there
will be more shocking death so beloved
characters as the show concludes because
it just makes sense in terms of
storytelling Nicholas said even the most
extreme things have been doing my story
that is point in the show you're reaping
the rewards of the work that's been put
into all these characters as an audience
member you're kind of invested into
every single one of these people which
is I should not talk about the ending
here finally Peter Dinklage who plays
here and Lannister also share its
thoughts about the final season I think
it's going to be the best season of
television anyone has ever seen it takes
to the place that you never saw coming
that's I didn't see coming here it just
be prepared it's a fun ride
so the game eternal stars promise that
the final season is going to be the best
season ever and it's ending will not
please everyone believe us see need for
therapy and that that will shock us at
the end there are many ways to end the
game drones in my opinion one of the
most likely ways the game eternal still
end is with just not dying fighting the
night King likely killing shatter Danny
dying in a childbirth and Tyrion being
named Lord regent and protector of the
realm to rule in John and Danish child
stead until the child comes of age this
ending sounds even more possible when
you remember that game transcending has
been promised to be bittersweet during
his rule Tyrion would like to break up
the Kingdom and allow the various parts
away to self-govern fulfilling the his
ratio breaking the wheel and in fact
ending the game in turns fast for all
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace